voici le terrain de la discorde pour un
montant de 700 mille euros il va être
rénovée par tour plus afin que les
hockeyeurs sur gazon dispose d'un stade
digne de ce nom mais à l'agglo les élus
d'opposition et surtout les verts
dénoncent une subvention déguisée pour
le football et donc au bénéfice du tfc
et des hockeyeurs ils sont très peu
nombreux c'est pas du tout un sport qui
a une portée au delà de la commune mais
on a utilisé cet argument fallacieux et
encore une fois tour plus démontré ses
limites puisque sans commission des
finances personne n'a pu réagir et poser
les bonnes questions ces sept cent mille
euros vraiment il faut les mettre
ailleurs on nous a annoncé un intérêt
communautaire pour le hockey on peut pas
reprocher ça à monsieur briand est ce
qu'on peut reprocher c'est qu'en
définitive il vaudrait mieux voir la
franchise de dire les choses c'est un
terrain de foot payé par l'agglo pour la
ville de tours et au moins le débat
aurait lieu en toute transparence au
sein de l'agglo au lieu d'essayer de
déguiser en terrain de hockey au
complexe sportif de la vallée du cher le
tours football club dispose déjà de deux
terrains synthétiques pour
l'entraînement à la mairie de tours on
réfute cette idée d'une troisième
surface pour le tfc on a fait et je
précise bien on a fait un terrain de
hockey sur gazon ce n'est pas un terrain
de foot et non pas les mêmes dimensions
terrain de hockey c'est 97 par 61 et
passant cinq par 65
c'est typiquement le genre
d'infrastructure qui correspond à la
définition de l'agglo à savoir une
structure particulière pour un sport
particulier un sport qui compte moins de
90 pratiquant sur l'agglomération
la mairie est tous plus veulent
encourager la pratique sportive coûte
que coûte les opposants à ce projet
aurait souhaité une utilisation beaucoup
plus écologique de ces sept cent mille
euros en période de restrictions
budgétaires